hello large bible i am james mcavoy i'm
sarah paulson i'm will smith i'm martin
lawrence jody koma i'm ryan reynolds i
am jake gyllenhaal i'm yaya abdul mateen
in the second lana condor i'm noah
sentinel i'm chris i'm tessa i'm kristen
stewart and i'm ella valencia and this
is first impressions from orlando
blood bubble i had bob
i'm so excited you should go first here
we go
a lion
wolverine
pterodactyl
jaws jaws
yes
[Applause]
this guy
donkey
shrek
you cute oh
ah
oh say more it's like
oh you cute
now see i'm not even supposed to be here
you know but i came up you know i don't
even see his money
it's money
i went to laguardia with with timmy
chalamet
um the nails
julie roberts what the [ __ ]
you know i
i was a stripper you know but now
what's the song is it [ __ ] yeah how does
it go do you want the explicit version
always are you yeah always out there
money moves
and diet gotta cut it yeah
cut it cut it
cut it hey hey
yes if i just
scoop this bit of rice out of the pan
and stick it under my tongue
and uh put it in the microwave oh i
don't know her name
i know it is though the one that makes
cooking super sexy
okay
oh wow um is it like
no is that what it is
it's more like
yes
and i don't know how to impersonate him
cheat
what i want to tell you today
what do you want to tell me
is that i know you miss me a lot
what one of the greatest guys hugh
jackman oh i don't know how to do it
it's not hugh jackman let me just maybe
say it no come on i'm american
oh you're american that narrows it down
i know you miss me a lot
i'm articulate kind
no people
barack obama
[Laughter]
is it barack obama barack obama oh my
god how do you impersonate him he sort
of talks a bit like this
oh yes
and he likes to throw it back and then
um
he can have my points
donald trump
you're an animal
giraffe
here we go again
a dinosaur from
[Laughter]
a lamb no coat
so it's like
and then it's like
don't mistake me for a shock
i'm a
dolphin yes yep
there you go see echolocation
what i'm a dolphin oh
a monster uh
a monster
king car
everybody
[Music]
godzilla godzilla no uh
it's a monster
it's uh
is it holding a white woman leonardo
dicaprio he got got beat up by one but
oh
a bear
yeah there you go all right
and you use this like a beard
okay
yes harry but not the person that i now
realize i look like i'm doing
harry
a buddy scottish right or something or i
think is he scottish as well i think
there's a scottish old person oh it's um
yes
oh oh oh oh my mommy always said life is
like a box of chocolates forest gum no
life is like a box of active grenades
you never know what you're going to get
very small and i have a napoleon complex
and um i don't know i'm on a tv show oh
oh
um cool whip go away you
i will not be drinking my milk
how dare you you wench
why i say everything is sort of like
this
i mean and his dad sort of talks a bit
like this he says um i am so sorry
because i'm feeling it all but i can't
think of the name pizza's my fault i
don't know
stewiegriffin.com i don't know this
darned i tried go again brian would you
change my nappy
oh um stewie yeah
stewie
um
okay okay oh wow it took it all up but
let me tell you it took a lot to get
there though right i mean it took you
you had to get through it
so um like like
all right
this way onward
lucky his name's kind of like a bird i'm
taking this game into something else
like charades captain hook no
is it de niro what the [ __ ] oh oh it's
not deniro it's captain jack sparrow oh
played kitchener
god i'm sorry
i'm captain jack sparrow
oh i'm oh yeah yeah the man from part of
the caribbean
[Laughter]
youtube are boxing uh
i i like to make music now
glover
[Laughter]
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm not a bird but i'm a tall being in a
movie with fenn i've got fur on me and
i'm making up sounds we're like
but that may not be what he does at all
i'm in a movie with lightsabers oh uh oh
chewbacca yeah yeah
this is a joke i made up when i was a
little boy who's the biggest
or guy that jacks off and star wars
who han solo
actually was green
and i'm crazy and that was first
impressions
i don't like ryan reynolds at all
absolutely
yeah
oh god some of that was deeply
embarrassing but you can use all of
it little hands
i'm so strong except for my little hands
t-rex yeah